ils sont des milliers à franchir chaque
jour la frontière moldave à palanga
c'est le poste frontière le plus proche
de la ville d'odessa au sud ouest de
l'ukraine où les forces russes se
rapproche beaucoup ont tout laissé
derrière eux pour fuir en voiture ou à
pied malgré des températures très basses
dans ses bras
cette femme sert son fils de trois ans
il a de la fièvre mais elle est
convaincue d'avoir pris la bonne
décision
j'ai mon fils est bien sûr je suis une
mère je veux juste protéger mon fils
parce que je veux vraiment quel avenir
il est une vie meilleure qu'aujourd'hui
il a tellement peur il pleure tout le
temps
la plupart de ces réfugiés sont des
femmes avec enfants ou des personnes
âgées ils sont accueillis par des
volontaires et cherche ensuite un
transport pour rejoindre chizy nos la
capitale moldave
dans ce hall d'exposition reconverti en
centre d'accueil les réfugiés se repose
mais la guerre est dans tous les esprits
nous sommes épuisés mentalement
si seulement dieu pouvait nous aider et
nous donner la paix
tout le monde pourrait vivre une vie
normale mais maintenant le monde entier
tremble
cet afflux de réfugiés représentent un
défi de taille pour ce petit pays de 2,6
millions d'habitants l'un des plus
pauvres d'europe pour venir en appui
huit mille couvertures de survie ont été
distribués par le haut commissariat au
défi